gordon ramsay headed to norway to learn
how to cook like a true viking but how
this region developed some of its
traditional dishes happened long before
these explorers took to the seas i want
to move to norway
[Music]
the sami people are indigenous to the
sampi region which includes northern
parts of norway sweden finland and
russia they're descendants of nomadic
peoples who've inhabited the region for
thousands of years
their population today is estimated to
be around 80 000 with about half
currently living in norway
despite their relatively small
population size sammy people have had a
huge influence on nordic culture and
even in feature films like frozen 2 but
one of their biggest influences is in
their cuisine
traditionally the sammy were
hunter-gatherers that feasted on
in-season berries and animal-based meals
like reindeer meat and fish
the meats were preserved through salting
and drying
communal reindeer herding later replaced
hunting and became an integral part of
the sami economy how many are in the
head
what's your fortune i think magna is
trying to tell me that it's rude to ask
a sammy about the size of their herd
culturally the sami people used all
parts of the animal so that nothing
would go to waste
are they warm yeah it's wrong
so you waste nothing no no no no waste
even the sheep i mean could you make
them my size size 15
expensive
animal byproducts like hides bones and
blood were used for clothing tools and
even other meals blood pancakes anyone
[Music]
i actually like the flavor
the texture's quite thick and dense and
now onto the vikings the viking age
started around the late 8th century
where danish norwegian and swedish
warriors took to the seas to raid and
colonize other parts of europe to meet
the high energy demands of a viking
lifestyle high-fat foods were a
necessity especially in winter months
vikings were comprised of independent
farmers and when on land they
surprisingly had a good amount of
variety in their diet
this included cereals animal milks wild
fruit and berries and a wide variety of
meat including horses pigs goats and
sheep this is a sheep's head
how far does this date back
fish and fresh shellfish like scallops
were also staples both at land and at
sea i'm amazed
how sweet they are that's a big shock
for me like the sammy vikings were not
known to let food go to waste domestic
animals were first used as working
animals then later eaten which led to
established delicacies like sheep's head
boiling meat and stews was a great way
to help meals stretch and stay flavorful
for example in a viking scouse meat and
vegetables were taken out of the pot
then replaced with new ones
this allowed for the broth to be extra
concentrated throughout the days of
cooking also like the sammy meat and
fish were often dried and salted for
long-term preservation
from the indigenous traditions of the
sammy to the conquering spirits of the
vikings norwegian cuisine and food
preparation has survived for centuries
and while some of the dishes may look a
little different today
the roots will remain for generations to
come
[Music]
want to see more from my uncharted
adventures please click here to watch
more clips